all right what up guys welcome
to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome to morning coffee
thoughts where I give my thoughts over
morning coffee so
today I'm going for a walk
I'm up early again I've I've been
quitting getting up early but now I'm
just in it I'm with it I'm with the
morning
I really do think morning people are
superior as a night owl
like I'll hear these creatives come in
and be like I have my best inspiration
at night and I'm like
guys when I started getting up in the
morning I would get it in the morning
like it's just a lack of discipline we
gotta work on this
um you know but
I guess my dad's the greatest man on the
planet the best guy I know
um and he he
I think he used to stay up late when I
was a kid
he would he would just work all the time
anyways Okay so
I was thinking about how
traditional men are punished nowadays
can you guys hear me I'm gonna go my
other hand just to make sure
okay I was thinking about how
traditional men
are really punished nowadays and how the
Trad cons will always come in
and we'll say hey
we are in a post-marriage society right
we're in a society that really punishes
men for doing the right thing
you go out and work for your children
boom your misses can take your money
take your money
um take your kids do blah blah blah
right okay
and the track cons will come in and
they'll just say just find a good woman
just just get a good woman
and I wanna I wanna talk about how
that's a little a little disingenuous
from my point of view okay
you're basically telling the average man
women have a nature right there there
are things that women do as a group not
everybody acts on our nature right it
doesn't mean you have to be a slave to
it but I think we can admit as women
there's things we tend to do
we tend to move on to better options
you know we break up with one guy move
on to the next we try to do better and
better and better
um we have a tendency to lie we see
everything with our emotions we feel
everything emotions first so I don't
even think we have a full grasp on
reality
we're not as smart as the men we don't
work as much as the Met like there's
just things about women
and what the Trad cons will do is deny
the nature of women
okay and they'll say you just gotta find
a woman without
you you have to find a woman that's not
a woman essentially because they'll say
well my wife would never leave she would
I would bet you all the money she would
never leave and I think a little bit
more honest answer as well she's still a
woman she might
um you know like
because again we just have this nature
doesn't mean we have to be a slave to it
but I've seen women that were good wives
for 20 years get the wrong friend group
get in them like um okay I know someone
right traditional woman out of high
school
um then
married to a guy for like 20 years
then at work
she like after the kids around a little
older she starts working again
becomes a lawyer right
then after
a couple years of that she ends up
falsely acute she gets really mad one
day falsely accuses him she ends up
dropping the charges but that's an
example of a good woman who let her
emotions get the best of her she's still
a woman and part of part of female
nature
really is that when we have leverage
we're not good people we cannot have too
much leverage in a relationship and you
got to look at what we as a group have
done
in the last hundred years right
we got leverage and basically broke up
our families right we we got leverage
and then we
put really unfair divorce laws we got
like every time women have leverage
and choice we just tend to choose the
wrong thing
and that's just women and
um so what they'll say is go go to uh
you know a small town in the middle of
nowhere
and get you a good woman now I'm not
saying good women don't exist right
um you know and my mom grew up in like a
super tiny town so like where my
grandma's from you know I see these
chicks in the middle of nowhere they're
still influenced by social media
you can't get away from this stuff
and the only way that I see real change
happening honestly is enough men
protesting and fixing the system
because as long as women have leverage
like that's what we saw with the Crowder
situation right well we're just gonna
keep doing it
and you know now we have a society
there's no social shame I mean we've
even seen tradcon influencers like right
the quote-unquote good women the tricon
influencers sue for sexual harassment
right and we've seen them
um divorce their husband like do the
exact same thing so what does that tell
you maybe it's just female nature maybe
it's just kind of how we are you know we
get really mad and get really emotional
we don't see reality we make stupid
decisions that's just kind of women and
that's why in history there's always
been protections
against female nature like they've known
this about chicks but Trad cons will
call the red pillars like doomsdayers
for saying it's bad to get married don't
do that
um
now
because men really have two options when
they look at it it's like yeah they can
give they can find a good woman
but that good woman is still in this
crazy Society there's still social media
I don't and women we feel something
different every goddamn day so it's like
and you're basically telling him that if
he opts to get a vasectomy right
or
he takes power back in any way and says
I'm not getting married not doing any of
this that really he's doing the wrong
thing and he should just resist
and this is why I personally
really I don't like to I don't like to
advise men I think it's weird when women
advisement like it's just not my thing I
just point out
there's a lot of different options here
and honestly for men there's no there's
no good option there's no like winning
because women are still women and we
live in a society that pretends We're
Men
but we're women so and you know it's
funny because what I keep getting is now
you're anti-woman I actually think I'm
more pro-women than you guys are
because as a chick it's a bit easier
when you understand your nature when you
understand
okay maybe I'm being dramatic because
I'm a woman or that you know you you see
things with your emotions but what's
mean is telling women that we're not
women and that
or equally as logical and credible as
men and that
we're so amazing and awesome that the
men should just marry us
I mean
not saying there aren't good women but
women are still women and we need to fix
the only then they're always like Pearl
what are your Solutions
well I really don't see anything
changing until men take power away from
women and that's why I always say you
know women shouldn't vote that's why I
always go back to this now maybe
it's that we switch it to not taxpayers
maybe there's other ways but regardless
women and men are so different
that women really shouldn't be making
these decisions and it's funny because
then they'll say well most most men
shouldn't vote either
and they just divert away from the real
problem which is women making decisions
like they'll be like guys let's just be
honest if we got rid of the female vote
that would solve a lot of stuff that
would solve a lot like come on and so
if dragon's want to go back to tradition
if Trad cons want things to switch
one we have to acknowledge the way women
are
and two we have to make policies keeping
that in mind and stop saying but men but
men but men we know we've had so many
conversations about the men I am so
tired of talking about the men and
tradcons do not help us they do they do
not by saying but men and diverting the
attention from the women and putting it
on the men for the millionth time it's
annoying
um so
do I does this make me anti-women or or
does this make me a realist I don't know
let me know in the comments like the
video subscribe to the channel I'll talk
to you next time